It is that time of year again.
It is summer.
And every summer I visit my grammy.
Ana comes, too.
Ana is my little sister.
Some of my friends asked,
"Why do you call her Grammy?"
"Well," I said.
"It's because she doesn't like to be called Grandma.
When we ask her why, she just laughs."
Our grammy is very cool.
She does things most grammies don't do.
She likes being silly.
Sometimes we call her Silly Grammy.
Ana and I were getting excited to visit Grammy.
So I called her on the phone.
Now I am going to share what Grammy said when I called her.
Then you'll know just how cool our grammy really is!
"I miss you!" said Grammy.
"We miss you, too!" I said.
"Come visit, and we will have a special vacation," said Grammy.
"What will we do?" I asked.
"You will get to see my new purple house," said Grammy.
"We will do lots of fun things."
"We will in-line skate in the park."
We will make circles, figure eights, and curlicues."
"We will put colored streamers on our bikes."
"And then we will parade through town."
"We will eat scrambled egg and pickle sandwiches in the park."
"We will read scary stories to each other."
"And we will put on funny plays for all the neighbors."
"We will play in the ocean waves."
"And we will gather shells to make castles in the sand."
"We will jump on the trampoline and see if we can touch the sky."
"And then," I said.
"We'll take a long nap in the big hammock under the oak tree!"
Just Ana, my cool grammy, and me!